bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur LCP dans
savoure garde ce soir l'éolien a tout
pris la crise énergétique crée un élan
sans précédent les députés débattent
toute cette semaine des moyens de
rattraper et vite le retard français sur
les énergies renouvelables mais à
quelles conditions plus d'éolienne en
mer et sur terre est-ce vraiment la
panacée pour les populations et
l'environnement grand débat ce soir à
suivre avec nos invités dans un instant
notre grand témoin est un grand flic
surnommé tour à tour le petit prince ou
Yvan Le Terrible il a dirigé la brigade
antigang de Paris dont il livre tous les
secrets dans un livre l'ancien
commissaire Yves Jobic sera avec nous
dans la deuxième partie en fin nous
affranchis ce soir le RN ou LFI qui
piège qui à l'Assemblée on verra cela
avec Stéphanie des pierres dans Palais
Bourbon Express le parti pris de l'écho
de Fanny guinochet Emmanuel Macron très
mécontent du plan comme autour des
coupures de courant et puis le regard
sur la d'Isabelle la sœur ce soir la
petite phrase de trop du président
français sur la Russie voilà pour le
menu c'est parti
s'il y a bien une chose que la crise
énergétique a permis c'est la prise de
conscience plus personne ne remet en
cause la nécessité d'accélérer sur les
énergies renouvelables mais à quel prix
bonsoir Paul midi bonsoir et bienvenue
sur ce plateau je vous voyais ticket
vous nous direz si vous avez dans
l'hémicycle des opposants à cette
assertion que je viens de donner en
plateau en préambule bonsoir Aurélie
bonsoir ravi de vous retrouver député la
France insoumise de Seine-Saint-Denis
vous ferrailler ou plus ou moins
d'ailleurs tous les deux dans
l'hémicycle en ce moment même bonsoir
Arnaud Gossement et merci d'être là vous
êtes avec avocat spécialisé en droit de
l'environnement les procédures sont
toujours extrêmement longues pour
implanter des éoliennes sur le
territoire on va essayer de comprendre
pourquoi exactement enfin Nicolas NAS de
Greenpeace chargé de la transition
énergétique pour cette ONG va nous jouir
rejoindre dans un tout petit instant
mais d'abord comme ça ce soir le
contexte et puis bien sûr le texte si
j'ai bien compris c'est l'ami blackovski
pour ouvrir le bal
bonsoir Stéphane bonsoir à toutes
bonsoir à tous si j'ai bien compris ce
soir alors si j'ai bien compris Myriam
c'est c'est la honte non mais c'est là
honte la France est le seul pays
européen qui a trahi ah j'aime pas ceci
ce mot la France 4 trahi ces engagements
sur les énergies renouvelables en 2009
on avait promis qu'on atteindrait
23% de notre consommation énergétique
avec les renouvelables à partir de 2020
sauf pour 2020 on était à 19% et on est
le seul pays d'Europe qui n'a pas
atteint son objectif non mais c'est là
où comment l'expliquer cette histoire là
franchement j'aimerais bien j'aimerais
vous balancer un nom en disant c'est lui
c'est de sa faute on mettrait sa photo
et on dirait on est enfin notre bouc
émissaire sauf que c'est peut-être un
peu plus compliqué puisque on a pris la
décision en 2009 depuis il y a eu nous
avons voté tout ce que nous sommes pour
trois présidents qui eux-mêmes ont des
initi 7 premiers ministres donc les
responsabilités sont un petit peu
diluées malgré tout donc on pourrait
aussi en déduire que finalement ils sont
tous aussi nuls les uns que les autres
mais comme disait l'autre périssent la
colère qui aveugle le plus sage on va
donc plaider les circonstances
attenantes je vais vous montrer un
graphique qui est beaucoup moins sexy
que le fait d'être désigner un bouc
émissaire vous voyez que la France elle
est complètement nulle en énergie
renouvelable mais en revanche quand on
regarde les émissions de CO2 on n'est
pas si nul que ça on est même plutôt
dans les 10 premiers dans le sens où on
aimait moins plutôt moins de CO2 que les
autres et pourquoi d'après vos Myriam le
nucléaire le nucléaire mais oui mais bon
si on avait pris sans doute tant de
retard dans le renouvelable c'est que au
départ on comptait sur le nucléaire
d'emploi alléger notre bilan carbone
sauf que à un moment le précédent Macron
il faut bien reconnaître qu'il a un
petit peu tergiversé parce que en 2018
nous a annoncer la fermeture de 14
réacteurs nucléaires et puis quatre ans
plus tard qu'est-ce qu'il fait c'est
exactement le contraire finalement on va
construire 14 nouveaux réacteurs
nucléaires le problème c'est que le
temps comprenait à hésiter sur tout ça
la crise de l'énergie nous a percuté et
là on est dans l'urgence on a tout le
temps il faut absolument
comme renouvelable c'est va plus vite
que le nucléaire et bien on veut
accélérer alors ce projet de loi que
dit-il précisément qu'est-ce qu'il veut
bah il dit qu'il veut accélérer il veut
accélérer parce que figurine que les
Allemands vont deux fois plus vite que
nous pour construire des éoliennes alors
pourquoi parce qu'ils sont meilleurs que
nous bien sûr que non ils sont éliminés
Coupe du Monde nous on est toujours là
donc franchement non parce que les
procédures administratives vont plus
vite en Allemagne donc en France je vous
cite les chiffres 75% des installations
de parc éoliennes finissent devant le
tribunal parce que les gens sont pas
contents donc ils protestent et ça 90%
des cas finalement le tribunal dit bah
si on va quand même l'installer sauf que
ça a pris en moyenne entre 2 et 4 ans on
va dire trois ans de retard pour le
temps d'examiner tous ces recours donc
l'idée c'est de délivrer des
autorisations plus rapidement peut-être
même un peu des dérogations pour les
installer en étant un peu moins
regardant pour aller plus vite donc ce
projet de loi va permettre de les
installer ces éoliennes en mer et sur
terre partout ça c'est l'inquiétude
notamment des républicains c'est vrai
qu'il faudrait que les mères disposent
d'un droit de veto pour dire moi je ne
veux pas sur ma commune qu'on installe
ni panneaux solaires ni éolienne en gros
voilà ce que disait Jérôme numérique qui
est donc des républicains
décidez à Paris de l'aménagement du
territoire sans prendre en considération
les effets de saturation la beauté de
nos paysages et les contraintes
naturelles ne seraient que folies donc
les républicains voient plutôt le côté
vers à moitié vide côté PS côté vert on
verra plutôt le côté à moitié plein du
verre parce que même Sandrine Rousseau a
mis un peu de côté sa radicalité en
disant moi je suis prête à m'abstenir
pour faire voter le projet de loi côté
les filles j'ai pas mis de sonore
Aurélie trouvère en parler tout à
l'heure mais on critique le fait de
déréguler et en fait de laisser leur
priver
s'emparer d'un marché qui devrait plutôt
être une comme c'est de la souveraineté
du domaine national avant de vous
laisser débatts je voudrais quand même
souligner que si ce projet de loi
toutefois devait être voté sans doute en
grande partie grâce à l'administre Agnès
panier renacher qui a réussi à avoir
l'unanimité au Sénat donc c'est quand
même
un joli exploit qui lors de déballage
assemblée était salée en tout cas par
les écolos parce qu'elle savait
faire des compromis et donc elle est
peut-être moins brillante que d'aucun
mais elle est aussi beaucoup moins
arrogante en écoute à nous aussi de
dépasser les clivage en nous inscrivant
dans les pas de l'appel de Johannesburg
lancé par Jacques Chirac du Grenelle de
l'environnement conduit par Nicolas
Sarkozy et Jean-Louis Borloo ou de
l'accord de Paris sur le climat porté
par François Hollande et Laurent Fabius
effectivement
des compromis je pense qu'il y avait
peut-être un peu mieux que les autres
mais on les trouvait premier bon point
de Stéphane blackovski ce soir merci
pour votre billet complet comme chaque
soir je voudrais qu'on s'arrête deux
secondes sur le diagnostic avant d'aller
sur le projet de loi Stéphane l'a bien
dit Paul midi la France est très en
retard si on prend sur l'Europe on est
en 17e position quand on regarde le mix
é l'éolien c'est 7% l'hydraulique 6% le
mix électrique la bioénergie 1% bon le
solaire là en ce moment il y a pas
beaucoup de soleil donc on est à 0% on a
pris des chiffres d'air te du mois
dernier le nucléaire 67 % et le gaz 15
%. voilà comment on produit
l'électricité dans notre pays comment
vous expliquez le retard franchement non
mais le retard il faut regarder bien sûr
qu'on veut accélérer la transition
écologique c'est très clair le président
l'a encore redit à sharm-elcher on a un
gros problème sur l'énergie puisque 65%
notre énergie elle est d'origine fossile
au Danemark par exemple
mais parce qu'on a été très bon sur le
nucléaire donc au global en Europe on
est plutôt très bon mais par contre par
rapport à nos ambitions c'est faire le
zéro carbone en 2050 c'est le premier
pays le premier grand pays au monde qui
sortira des énergies fossiles et donc
nous il faut qu'on accélère
à ne pas respecter ses objectifs fixés
nous payons des centaines de millions
d'euros vous l'expliquez centaines de
millions d'euros
un souci du paysage en France on reste
sur l'éolien plus important je ne vous
ai pas coupé donc allez-y laissez moi
parler donc sur sur les énergies
renouvelables je vais vous dire ce qu'il
aurait fallu faire de notre point de vue
dans cette loi pour que ce soit
réellement efficace d'abord une
planification cette loi c'est tout sauf
la planification c'est à dire il n'y a
pas d'objectif chiffrés ces objectifs
chiffrés ne sont pas contraignants hier
soir nous avons proposé des amendements
pour qu'au moins les objectifs qui ne
vont arriver que dans quelques mois
parce que vous faites les choses à
l'envers que ces objectifs qui seront
fixés dans la loi de programmation
énergie climat au moins à l'avenir il
soit contraignant un peu les états
beaucoup plus ambitieux vous les avez
longtemps fait sauter voilà et ça ne
sera pas contraignant ensuite il n'y a
pas disons de financement public associé
et d'ailleurs c'est ce qui amène par
exemple sur le photovoltaïque vous j'ai
mis un article enfin il y avait un
article pardon qui puisse développer
massivement le photovoltaïque notamment
sur les bâtiments publics évidemment les
collectivités locales ont demandé à le
faire sauter puisque vous ne mettez pas
de financement que vous avez beaucoup
beaucoup d'arguments beaucoup
d'amendements on va y venir sur le fond
ma question c'était vraiment cette
comprendre de façon un peu apaisée
pourquoi on en est là aujourd'hui Arnaud
cosmo vous vous défendez tous les côtés
dans les plutôt enfin ça vous est arrivé
déjà en tant qu'avocat d'essayer
d'annuler d'annuler un projet d'éolienne
ou pas
de faire annuler je n'ai défendu que des
parquets éolien solaire etc
non expliquez-nous simplement
quelles sont les différentes étapes pour
bien comprendre de façon un peu voilà
résumé schématique pour arriver entre le
projet et la première pierre pour un
parc éolien pourquoi c'est si long 10
ans pour voir le jour le parc éolien de
Saint-Nazaire
c'est si long parce que de loin en loi
depuis 20 ans on a souhaité donner des
garanties la droite comme la gauche
d'ailleurs sous Nicolas Sarkozy ou
François Hollande a souhaité d'aider des
garanties à chacun c'est à dire qu'on a
souhaité satisfaire chacun les
associations anti-inerables les
associations défenses de l'environnement
les associations de défense des animaux
les associations défendent du paysage
des élus locaux de tout bord etc on a
fait des textes de compromis quand on
fait un texte de compromis je ne cherche
pas du tout à adresser des reproches à
qui que ce soit mais forcément c'est
comme en matière diplomatique on aboutit
à des textes plus complexes avec des
procédures qui viennent s'additionner
mais pour tenter donner raison à tous et
au final effectivement on se retrouve
avec des procédures qui en elle-même
sont longues parce qu'on veut regarder
beaucoup de choses on veut regarder le
paysage on veut regarder les espèces
protégées on veut regarder le potentiel
de développement d'un territoire une
étape qui prend plus de temps que
d'autres on parle de l'enquête publique
on lui débat citoyens les recours
judiciaires les politiques qui vont
arriver les élections aussi qui disent
les là j'attends avant de donner une
décision administrative de manière
générale c'est le préfet qui va la
piloter pourquoi parce qu'il a tout
simplement les services des ingénieurs
des mines qui sont compétents le maire
d'une petite commune ne peut pas
instruire un projet par éolien ou de
géothermie donc il va s'en remettre au
service des ingénieurs qui sont eu
spécialisés qui ont pour analyser le
texte la pression administrative le plus
long c'est de faire ce qu'on appelle
l'évaluation environnementale regardez
l'air l'eau le sol etc etc mettent au
point ce document le faire valider par
plusieurs institutions parce qu'au final
sur toute une posture administrative il
y a à peu près une vingtaine d'autorités
qui va se prononcer sur votre dossier
entre les élus locaux etc l'enquête
publique elle-même c'est un mois donc
c'est pas ce qui va durer le plus
longtemps mais dans des grands projets
par exemple en mer on va faire un grand
débat public en amont de cette
configuration et effectivement ensuite
100% des projets de parc en mer sont
attaqués devant le juge on dit à peu
près 70% pour ce qui est de l'éolien
terrestre et ces recours il y a un droit
au recours mais parfois effectivement
ces recours sont utilisés pour faire des
recours donc c'est la partie recours
judiciaire qui fait traîner et on n'a
jamais réussi effectivement à trouver un
juste équilibre entre diminuer les
délais de recours diminuer et préserver
aussi le droit recours qui doit exister
bien entendu on essaie de voir de
comprendre avant d'arriver au texte
bonsoir Nicolas c'est merci d'être là
vous êtes chargé de la campagne
transition énergétique à Greenpeace donc
on a commis pas mal d'erreurs on se rend
compte aujourd'hui y compris dans la
répartition des éoliennes sur les
territoires français quand on regarde la
carte on va voir deux cartes une où on
voit les zones venteuses on va la voir
s'afficher vous allez pouvoir l'avoir là
où c'est très très bleu c'est là où il y
a le plus de vent donc on voit très bien
tout le nord de la France la côte
bretonne le sud-est et puis on a
installé les éoliennes va pas exactement
au même endroit beaucoup dans le Nord
beaucoup à l'est c'est à dire que c'est
pas là où il y a le plus de vent est-ce
qu'il y a eu un problème au fond dans la
répartition dans la juste répartition
des éoliennes sur le territoire et bien
sûr il y a eu une incohérence d'un point
de vue du pouvoir politique qui n'a pas
mis en place une vraie transition
énergétique qui soit planifiée sur les
territoires jusqu'à l'an dernier et la
loi de climat résilience il y avait
aucune planification territoriale et
effectivement aujourd'hui on se retrouve
avec deux régions les hauts de France et
le Grand Est ce qui concentre 50% donc
la moitié des éoliennes françaises alors
que comme on le voit c'est pas justifié
les éoliennes c'était pendant la
campagne cette phrase choc vous pouvez
la comprendre voix Greenpeace c'est pas
forcément quelque chose d'illégitting il
y a aussi un problème d'acceptabilité
alors on est totalement contre un
moratoire sur les éoliennes où que ce
soit après effectivement sur certains
villages très particulier qui peuvent
être entourés de nombreux parcs on peut
comprendre le sentiment d'injustice une
partie de la population qui se retrouve
entourée de plusieurs parcs éoliens
alors que ailleurs sur le territoire il
y en a pas du tout très peu donc il y a
vraiment un vrai sentiment d'injustice
aussi parce qu'il y a un manque de
compréhension de la part des citoyens
des citoyens de ce que c'est la
transition énergétique pourquoi on a
besoin des énergies renouvelables pour
arriver à nos objectifs climatiques et
en plus depuis cette année face à la
crise énergétique de grande ampleur d'où
l'importance de la planification Arnaud
gosse rapidement et puis on va voir in
situ à Belle-Île comment ça se passe
très rapidement sur cette carte parce
que juste la complexité du sujet si on
veut bien rentrer dedans vous dites à
l'endroit où il y a du vent par exemple
il y a pas beaucoup d'éoliennes c'est
vrai qu'en bord de mer ou en haut d'une
montagne c'est là où il y aurait le plus
de vent on devrait aller sauf que depuis
1985 et 86 on a la loi montagne et la
loi littorale qu'on doit respecter et on
ne peut pas construire cet endroit-là
c'est pas qu'on a voulu concentrer les
parcs à cet endroit là c'est qu'on a
voulu respecter la législation mentale
et la législation électorale à laquelle
tout le monde est attaché c'est vous
comprenez la complexité du sujet à un
moment donné il faut respecter plusieurs
contraintes qui sont toutes légitimes
l'État et face à des injonctions
contradictoires et il doit se dépêtrer
avec ça donc attention à ne pas
simplifier la justement pour
corrigerait qui serait trop simple on va
quand même regarder ce reportage parce
qu'il est vraiment très instructif et je
vous laisse débattre du texte juste
après c'est Marion Becker qui s'est
rendu à Belle-Île et vous allez le voir
sur place le projet offshore flottant
d'éoliennes est très contestée à la fois
par les pêcheurs mais aussi par les
habitants reportages
c'est ici au large de Quiberon entre
Belle-Île et Groix que doit voir le jour
le premier parc éolien flottant français
15 éoliennes de 260 mètres de haut qui
produiront 250 MW de quoi fournir de
l'électricité à 450 000 habitants mais
ces éoliennes sont loin de faire
l'unanimité
nous avons été les éoliennes flottantes
comme pouvant être éloigné des côtes
justement pour préserver les paysages or
là on nous les met à une vingtaine de
kilomètres de Belline pour nous cette
zone est inadmissible tout kilomètre
gagné sera déjà 1 km de gagner moi je
veux
c'est de la merde et moi je vais vous
expliquer un peu mais on a une belle
criée à Quiberon qui vend du poisson du
poisson du beau poisson
le député les élus et les associations
ce sont mobilisés pour repousser les
éoliennes préserver les paysages et
cette côte sauvage regardez-moi comme
c'est beau voilà on est pas mal parce
qu'on a un bon panorama parce qu'on est
pile poil là sur le lieu d'implantation
ici
devant vous voyez la à 15 km à peu près
la taille d'une tour Eiffel selon
l'alignement plus on les verra plus ou
moins façon le champ industriel
évidemment ça fait mal au cas ça fait
mal au cœur le consensus il est pas loin
il est un petit peu plus loin c'est tout
ce qu'on demande
et les maires de Belle-Île voudrait que
les éoliennes soient installés au-delà
de la limite des eaux territoriales ils
espèrent que les éoliennes seront placés
le plus à l'ouest possible de la zone
définie par l'État mais les pêcheurs eux
veulent un autre emplacement dans les
eaux territoriales et plus à l'est
ce dossier cache aussi un enjeu
financier
si le parc est implanté dans les eaux
territoriales les pêcheurs toucheraient
1,4 millions d'euros chaque année
nous avec des professionnels la
condition a été que la continuité de
l'activité de pêche présente dans cette
zone puisse continuer telle qu'elle est
aujourd'hui on ne peut pas jouer avec la
vie des pêcheurs et de leur famille dans
ce bras de fer local la ministre a
choisi les pêcheurs touchez mais pas
couler le député continue son combat
pour faire adopter son amendement dans
la future loi pour que tous les parcs
éoliens soient implantés loin des côtes
convaincre mes collègues parlementaires
c'est ce que je vais essayer de faire
mais hélas
je risque de me servir de cet exemple
comme étant quelque chose à ne pas faire
et j'ai peur sincèrement que que
j'allais dire que la fronde locale mais
que que ce qui va se dire un petit peu
localement ne va pas aider à ses parcs
of short dont on a besoin pour notre
souveraineté énergétique
l'exemple de Belle-Île s'invitera
certainement dans l'hémicycle lors de
l'examen de la loi
voilà pour ce reportage Paul million on
a choisi forcément l'éolien marin
puisque c'est ce que développer le
président de la République 50 parc
éolien offshore d'ici 2050 mais même à
Belle-Île là on est dans un cas
spécifique de flottant il y a énormément
de contestations sur la règle des CAC 40
km réclamés par votre votre collègue du
modèle ce serait possible de lui
accorder cette exception pas plus de
voilà les éoliennes après les 40 km des
côtes
qui a été voté à la quasi inanimité au
Sénat mais ce qui est très important de
comprendre c'est effectivement ce qui va
avoir le plus d'impact sur notre paysage
c'est le dérèglement climatique et ça
c'est irréversible donc ça il faut bien
l'avoir en tête donc la première des
priorités c'est de lutter contre le
dérèglement climatique et donc on doit
développer les énergies renouvelables et
on doit développer ses éoliennes mais
par contre il faut limiter évidemment le
plus possible les nuisances pour ceux
qui habitent autour et c'est pour ça
vous avez raison que nous on a mis le
paquet en mettant l'objectif sur 50
parcs éoliens offshoptabilité est
difficile aussi hein
c'est pour ça que dans ce texte à la
fois on veut accélérer très fortement
sur toutes les procédures mais il faut
que tout le monde puisse être consulter
on rentre pas dans une dictature on veut
juste accélérer très fortement et se
mettre au moins au standard européen et
ça c'est ce que permet ce texte et après
il fera garder des concertations locales
à chacun des endroits pour limiter le
plus possible prendre en compte la vie
économique les pêcheurs pour chacun des
projets qui sont à chaque fois
différents alors là les pêcheurs eux ils
aimeraient rester à moins de 40 km c'est
les habitants qui veulent pas voir les
éoliennes vous pourrez rien de sensible
à ce genre d'argument les côtes
bretonnes l'île de Groix Belle-Île ne
veut pas voir ces éoliennes apportées
d'abord il faut rappeler que entre 60 et
80% des Français ont une vision positive
des éoliennes donc il faut voilà il faut
revenir à des chiffres ensuite il faut
faire en sorte qu'il y ait une accep
rentabilité sociale et pour ça de mon
point de vue le texte va dans le mauvais
sens parce que d'abord vous vous allez
faire passer certaines voies de
consultation par voie électronique nous
nous demandons et ça sera une ligne
rouge qui est des débats et des
consultations publiques au niveau de la
commune pour nous ça va accélérer
l'acceptabilité sociale et donc le
développement des énergies renouvelables
et ça a été dit je pense que ce qui est
clé c'est la planification territoriale
et là nous avons un problème aussi parce
que ce qui est bientôt prévu dans le
fameux article 3 pour nous ça nous les
gens n'ont pas suivi comme vous le texte
je crois je vais m'expliquer c'est tout
l'article qui aura sur la planification
la soi-disante planification nous ce
qu'on dit c'est que ce texte en fait il
va pas faire grand chose parce que
d'abord il se il s'appuie sur la main
visible du marché grosso modo
c'est-à-dire c'est essentiellement une
levée de contraintes pour les
entreprises nous ce qu'on pense c'est
qu'il faut une véritable planification
territoriale avec des zones concertées
décidées ou lier les accélération des
énergies renouvelables en fonction des
différentes contraintes et que ce ne
soit pas possible à côté et ça pour
l'instant pour vous le fait que ce soit
des promoteurs privés qui
occupent le marché de l'éolien c'est un
problème il faut qu'il se soit en tout
cas piloté au niveau national et au
niveau territorial par des opérateurs
publics et ensuite il faut des
contraintes sur les opérateurs privés
bien évidemment et je le dis aussi il y
a dans ce texte aussi le problème de du
poids des lobbies qui ont qui ont été
forts par exemple les grandes
entreprises commerciales je vois que sur
le photovoltaïque il y a des choses qui
ont sauté d'ailleurs en commission par
exemple sur le fait de pouvoir
développer avec des contraintes beaucoup
plus fortes sur les toits des bâtiments
commerciaux comme public donc voilà il
faut non seulement des contraintes sur
les opérateurs privés et puis il faut
une un opérateur public et ça toute la
nuit passée là-dessus idéalement il
faudrait nous si on avait si on était au
gouvernement nous aurions un grand
opérateur public de l'énergie qui puisse
planifier territorialement à nous poser
conditions c'est très très clair
arnaud-gossement pour bien comprendre il
y a un marché de l'éolien on essaye de
rester sur un sujet parce que sinon
c'est extrêmement large il y a un marché
éolien il y a des opérateurs et puis on
entend le sujet qu'on a vu la surbellie
il y a aussi un peu un business parce
que il y a des compensations il y a des
compensations financières les pêcheurs
voilà compte aussi dessus comment ça se
passe exactement la question de l'argent
avec les liens alors pour répondre à la
question de l'argent il faut d'abord
répondre à la question du droit et
rappeler au téléspectateurs que
l'ensemble de nos objectifs des
principes et parfois même dans le détail
des procédures pour autoriser contrôler
ces parcs éoliens sont de la compétence
de l'Union européenne actuellement la
Commission européenne négocier que le
Parlement et le Conseil des Ministres de
l'Union européenne un grand plan qu'on
appelle le plan ripower pour répondre à
la crise ukrainienne et dans ce plan
REpower vous avez un certain nombre de
mesures que le Gouvernement français a
souhaité anticiper dans ce texte moi là
si j'avais un message à faire passer au
parlementaire avant toute chose c'est de
s'assurer que ce qu'ils vont voter est
compatible avec le texte européen vous
avez cité à l'instant la planification
par exemple c'est typiquement une mesure
qui est dans la proposition qui a été
faite par la Commission européenne qui
doit être trans
en partie d'abonder les comités des
pêches c'est une demande qui a été faite
par eux mais dès les années 10 c'était
sous Nicolas Sarkozy à ce moment-là ça
avait été négocié consensuel d'ailleurs
et ça va ramener effectivement des des
subsides alors toujours sur la question
de l'acceptabilité je reviens vers vous
dans un instant nous sommes en duplex de
la salle des quatre colonnes à
l'Assemblée nationale avec Monsieur
Emmanuel Macquet vous êtes député les
républicains bonsoir et merci d'avoir
patienter les républicains qui réclament
un véritable droit de veto pour les
mères en matière de projet éolien
notamment un droit de regard ne vous
suffirait pas la condition c'est un est
un veto strict pour les mers pour voter
ce texte
alors on peut appeler sa veto ou un avis
conforme en tout cas ce que l'on
souhaite c'est effectivement un
processus ascendant qui partent des
territoires avec la validation des
territoires en fonction de la
programmation plus réelle de l'énergie
et qui laisse la main effectivement au
territoire de façon plus être confrontée
aux difficultés que nous ressentons et
moi dans mon département de la Somme je
les ressens peut-être plus qu'ailleurs
de de ces tensions que nous rencontrons
sont sur les territoires aujourd'hui en
travers une démarche des promoteurs qui
de temps en temps et bien souvent un peu
agressive et qui pose de plus en plus de
difficultés dans des territoires qui
sont encerclés par les éoliennes
aujourd'hui au Sénat l'unanimité a été
trouvée avec un avis conforme des élus
des mers donc qui permettraient si j'ai
bien compris d'avoir la possibilité de
dire de valider ou non les zones
retenues pour les éoliennes ça ça va
dans le bon sens ça vous permettrait de
voter le texte ça ou vous voulez aller
plus loin jusqu'à un veto strict
non le leveto la vie conforme c'est la
même chose la difficulté à laquelle on
est confronté c'est que tout ça
nécessite de remodifier les documents
d'urbanisme qui aujourd'hui sont en
place sur nos territoires ce qui veut
dire que il nous faut 18 mois 36 mois
avant que ces documents ne soient
validés par les territoires que se
passe-t-il pendant ces mois et ses
années qui nous séparent de la mise en
œuvre de ces documents et bien c'est là
où l'intérêt public majeur que l'on
souhaite que le gouvernement souhaite
faire voter dans ce texte risque de
bousculer et risque d'accélérer
l'installation des éoliennes sur les
territoires sans avis cette fois-ci des
élus locaux c'est là le danger et c'est
là où nous demandons des garanties on
serait tout à fait disposés pourquoi pas
soutenir le texte s'il y avait un
moratoire tant que ces dispositifs ne
sont pas votés tant qu'ils ne sont pas
opposables en quelque sorte au
dispositif mais on va tout de suite
poser la question à Paul midi merci
beaucoup Emmanuel Maquet un moratoire en
attendant justement que les projets
soient clarifier je pense que c'est je
pense que c'était exclu mais le de veto
aussi mais le Sénat a lui-même trouvé un
meilleur compromis c'est à mettre les
mères au cœur de la planification sur
ces sujets et que les mères puissent
définir qu'est-ce qui est la zone
géographique dans laquelle c'est ouvert
aux éoliennes et aux énergies
renouvelables les zones qui ne sont pas
ouvertes à ça et donc de le mettre au
coeur de la planification
eux-mêmes la décision ça veut dire quoi
l'éolienne soit sur cette zone il y aura
pas d'éolienne mais les mères eux-mêmes
ne veulent pas que pour chacun des
projets ils aient le droit de veto ou
pas parce que ça les met dans une
situation qui est parfois impossible et
donc qui soit au coeur de la
planification sur leur territoire parce
qu'ils se retrouvent parfois pris entre
deux feux et c'est une décision qui
parfois lourde à prendre et parfois ça
c'est plus facile pour eux quand ils ont
dans une interne
qui serait content d'un avis conforme
quelques trouver au Sénat et les
républicains qui valaient plus loin
c'est ça
ils n'en veulent pas et c'est pour ça
que le Sénat avec le élus par les élus
locaux et en particulier les mers sont
souvent des fervents défenseurs des mers
ont trouvé le bon compromis pour tout le
monde et en particulier pour les mères
qu'on met au cœur de la planification
écologique alors Nicolas j'aimerais vous
interroger on entend voilà une demande
de garde-fou sur les mers les élus il y
a aussi des garde-fous sur la
biodiversité j'imagine qu'il y a
Greenpeace vous êtes sensible à cette
question là les éoliennes c'est pas à la
panacée pour la biodiversité qu'on
célèbre entre guillemets à la COP15
alors juste pour revenir rapidement sur
ce qui vient d'être dit je trouve assez
grave qu'en 2022 on a des députés de la
République qui continuent à dire qu'il
faut un moratoire pour geler un plan
plantation d'éolienne on est en pleine
crise énergétique où on va
potentiellement avoir des coupures
d'électricité on a des prix d'énergie
qui atteignent des niveaux records
l'éolien c'est que le solaire la seule
filière qui peut être développée avant
2030 en tout cas accéléré avant 2030
puisque l'éolien en mer se sera plutôt à
partir de 2030
alors effectivement ça veut pas dire
qu'il faut implanter sans réfléchir pas
trop elle va vite des éoliennes
terrestres partout évidemment il faut la
consultation il faut prendre en compte
l'impact sur la biodiversité aujourd'hui
c'est le cas
sont par exemple sur la consultation de
certaines autorités d'environnementales
non aujourd'hui dans la version actuelle
du texte pour nous il y a pas de ligne
rouge sur la partie biodiversité en tout
cas voilà il y a quelques points qui
pourraient améliorer mais il y a pas de
vraies lignes rouges c'est important ça
a été dit mais c'est important de
rappeler qu'effectivement le premier
impact sur biodiversité ça va être le
changement climatique ça aide le
réchauffement climatique c'est lui qui
va menacer en premier lieu des espèces
donc c'est vraiment oui important
d'encadrer et de prendre en compte
l'autorité environnementale enfin ce
qu'elle analyse environnementales mais
il est vraiment nécessaire d'accélérer
ce renouvelable et c'est vraiment le
message important
alors Aurélie trouver je vous donne la
parole dans un instant mais je voudrais
vous montrer que y compris au sein de la
gauche il y a des divisions sur cette
question de l'acceptabilité et y compris
dans votre propre camp votre majorité
avec le modèle on va écouter ces deux
députés c'était tout à l'heure dans
l'hémicycle
lorsque vous avez des machines de plus
de 180 mètres de haut à 500 mètres de
votre maison d'habitation et on en a
encore aujourd'hui qui s'installe c'est
juste invivable pour les habitants qui
sont à proximité si vous travaillez par
dans ce texte
améliorer un peu la justice territoriale
à diminuer un peu l'humiliation
territoriale que représente le
développement des eénères dans un
certain nombre de territoires alors vous
ne progresserez pas y compris dans votre
volonté de développer des ELR voilà
c'est un communiste qui dit attention
l'acceptabilité elle est pas si évidente
que ça surtout quand elle est chez soi
l'éolienne terrestre ou bien sûr mais ça
on ne le enfin je veux dire on est
d'accord là dessus il faut améliorer
l'acceptibilité sociale c'est d'ailleurs
pour ça que nous on se bat contre par
exemple un des articles qui va dire il
faut plus de consultation par voie
électronique et pas alors qu'il y en a
plein qui souffrent je veux dire qui qui
n'ont pas d'ordinateur etc qui ne
pourront pas donner leur avis d'y aller
vous pourriez bouger là donc prendre le
temps de se voir pour se parler
physique sans qui est tout le temps
d'obligation mais il y a toujours des
débats en physique et c'est très
important qui est les deux en physique
en numérique nous demandons nous verrons
si vous acceptez faire si vous voilà
votre est pour ce que nous demandons
c'est-à-dire quand il y a pas il quand
il voit électronique d'accord mais il
faut aussi qu'il y ait une consultation
physique alors je voudrais juste aussi
agir sur la question des éoliennes parce
que je pense qu'on peut pas la réfléchir
sans le mix énergétique c'est à dire que
là il y a un vrai besoin d'accélérer les
énergies renouvelables qui sont qu'on
peut développer là dans les années à
venir et là pour moi il y a aussi des
gros mots qui pour nous pèse et on a une
vraie cohésion là dessus il y a des gros
manques dans le texte notamment sur la
géothermie je veux dire ce matin j'étais
à Noisy-le-Sec ou voilà les les
responsables me disaient mais en fait on
peut arriver à dans des milieux dans
urbain à 20% de chaleur qui puisse être
prodigués grâce à la permis et au puits
voilà au forage pardon dans le texte
également il n'y a rien sur la
relocalisation des filières mais aussi
le développement la structuration des
filières par exemple sur la géothermie
on manque de bureau d'études on manque
d'entreprise de forage et il y a
beaucoup de matériel par ailleurs des
énergies renouvelables les panneaux etc
qui viennent essentiellement de Chine et
en même temps il y a quand même des
voies de passage parce qu'il y a
j'entends quelques concessions à
médiateur sur les EnR qui est proposé
par les écolos sans doute sera-t-il dans
le texte utiliser au maximum les les
zones déjà artificialisées pour
installer des ENR toiture parking etc il
y a quand même on sent une volonté de
trouver bien avec vous notamment croyez
vous pensez bien que nous avons des
lignes rouges qui sont bien plus fortes
que ça on va pas voter pour parce qu'il
y a un observatoire et un médiateur en
plus on votera pour parce que par
exemple on enlèvera l'hydrogène bas
carbone de ce texte qui n'a rien à y
faire je veux dire c'est quand même le
cheval de Troie du nucléaire c'est vous
savez qu'aujourd'hui c'est pas c'est un
vecteur vous le savez bien et qu'est-ce
que ça fait dans ce texte de loi alors
que c'est essentiellement produit
aujourd'hui par le nucléaire et à côté
de ça il y a pas la géothermie donc on
vous répondez on a essayé de faire un
petit peu le tour des des questions il y
a une main tendue des conditions posées
est-ce que vous êtes au travail qui a
été fait en commission et qui a continué
d'être fait en hémicycle il y a
plusieurs centaines d'amendements qui
ont été pris sur ce texte et j'espère
moi qu'on verra les oppositions
raisonnables le voter en particulier les
collègues du PS et de LV je serai très
étonné si une votez pas ce texte si on
croit à la transition écologique il faut
voter ce texte ou alors ça veut dire
soit on n'y croit pas si on y croit mais
qu'on fait de la politique aille et ça
ça serait irresponsable pour la France
en tout cas on voit vers qui la main est
tendue c'est clairement vers la gauche
de l'hémicycle pour ce texte particulier
merci beaucoup merci pour votre
expertise d'avoir balayé ce débat qui
passionnant mais assez technique aussi
merci à vous on va accueillir à présent
notre grand témoin je vous le disais
dans le sommaire c'est un grand flic sa
vie un Carna elle seule l'histoire de la
police parisienne il publie les secrets
de l'Antigone chez plomb en pleine
polémique sur la réforme de la police
judiciaire c'est sa famille de cœur
l'ancien commissaire Yves Jobic nous
rejoint juste après l'invitation signé
ce soir par MyTF1
Jobic c'est parce que vous la légende de
la police judiciaire vous publiez vos
mémoires les secrets de l'antigang flic
indique et coût tordu 500 pages qui
retrace 41 années de votre vie au
service de la police parisienne vous y
racontez une vie d'enquête au contact de
caïd et de cette culture des indics
c'est pas par le plaisir de contacter
des et de fréquenter des voyous c'est
parce que on ne fait pas de bonne police
judiciaire sans bons informateur vous
êtes le dernier chef de la brigade
antigang la BRI dans votre livre vous
revenez sur vos terrains de chasse sur
les braqueurs les ripoux et vous en
faites des portraits Francis le Belge
figure du Milieu marseillais Momo le
spécialiste des grands coups Jean Irina
dit Jamal votre meilleur indique mais
aussi le plus grand voleur de bijoux du
20e bague à 5000 euros montre à 30000
colliers à 150 000 et puis ce diamant
pas encore estimé mais qui pourrait
faire 25 carats
il est
aussi fait par la case prison s'était en
1988 17 jours de détention un cauchemar
médiatique au judiciaire dans lequel
vous plonge un de vos indics qui vous
accuse de proxénétisme après 18 mois de
bataille vous êtes totalement blanchi
par la justice j'étais victime une
machination de la part de voyous qui ont
voulu se venger et j'étais victime d'une
erreur judiciaire dans ce livre vous
revenez également sur les différents
réformes de la police au fil des années
à commencer par celle de 1999 on a coupé
la police judiciaire de ces services de
terrain de ces capteurs de terrain qui
permettaient d'avoir accès à toutes les
informations et de les faire remonter la
police judiciaire votre famille est
aujourd'hui en crise sous le coup d'une
réforme voulue par le gouvernement jeune
retraitée vous avez rendu vos insignes
une question Yves Jobic quelles
évolutions pour la police
dans les prochaines années
bonsoir Yves Jobic et merci beaucoup
d'être là c'est vrai que votre livre
tombe en pleine polémique sur cette
réforme on va en parler dans un instant
mais je voulais vous demander au fond
cette police que vous aimez cette police
antigang de haut niveau vous racontez
toutes les anecdotes de votre carrière
et elles sont très nombreuses on va y
venir comment elle va aujourd'hui est-ce
que vous avez pas l'impression qu'elle a
vécu ses meilleures années alors je
parle pas spécialement de la police en
qui mais plutôt de la police en général
je pense que elle traverse une période
difficile parce que les policiers de
toutes directions confondues dont de
meilleures de même et la situation pour
eux est quand même très compliqué la
police est beaucoup moins respectée
qu'elle ne l'était il y a plusieurs
dizaines d'années
il y a un certain laxisme judiciaire qui
fait que des comportements tout à fait
scandaleux ne sont pas réprimés
c'est une des difficultés mais je veux
dire que quand j'ai commencé les
agressions envers les policiers étaient
assez rares et elles étaient
systématiquement sanctionnées de peine
de prison voilà donc il y avait une
dissuasion qui existait et maintenant
la le métier et les rendu beaucoup plus
difficile qu'auparavant alors justement
on va essayer d'y comprendre un petit
peu quelque chose dans dans la police
que vous décrivez d'abord qu'est-ce que
la PJ et qu'est-ce que la BRI que vous
avez dirigé alors la police judiciaires
c'est une des directions actives de la
police nationale et qui est chargé de
lutter contre les crimes et des lits
principalement les crimes de moyenne et
haute intensité dans le spectre de la
délinquance et la BRI la Berri de Paris
que j'ai eu l'honneur de diriger pendant
6 ans qu'on appelait la brigade antigang
était une des brigade centrale du quai
des Orfèvres qui télécharger de lutter
d'initiative contre des grosses équipes
de voyous pour la plupart fichiers au
grand banditisme et de les suivre
pendant plusieurs semaines plusieurs
mois pour les interpeller en flagrant
délit donc à la suite de ça en province
qui ont été créés mais bon la bière il
parisienne c'était mythique mais elle a
aussi changé de mission après mon départ
à la suite notamment de d'une volonté
d'un directeur qui est arrivé en 1997
Patrick Rioux qui a voulu
que le 36 des Orfèvres soit beaucoup
moins offensifs et dynamique qu'il ne
l'était auparavant
démantelés avant de déménager bien sûr
aujourd'hui comme disait Marx l'histoire
bégaye et il y a eu deux actes en fait
dans
l'affaiblissement de la police
judiciaire en France la police
judiciaire était quand même une filière
d'excellence qui était admirée par tous
nos pays par les étrangers et en France
bon on les souvent les il était
difficile d'intégrer la police
judiciaire c'était vraiment une filière
de très grande qualité il y a eu
l'acteur de la réforme de la police
judiciaire que j'ai vécu et que j'ai
donc qui m'a rendu très malheureux en
1999 quand on a créé à Paris la police
urbaine de proximité sous Jospin Lionel
Jospin là on a cassé le quai des
Orfèvres en lui enlevé le tiers de ses
effectifs pour les faire passer à la
sécurité publique
aussi dans ce livre parce que c'est
comment raconter le passé à l'aune à
l'aune du présent on se plonge un peu
dans le passé c'est un livre sur la
culture de l'indique ces indices ces
informations que vous avez très bien
connu ils ont évolué on les a encadrés
mais c'est quoi la culture de l'indique
Jamal le magicien
Uggy face d'ange qui sont-ils ces beaux
voyous dont vous parlez et existe-t-il
encore aujourd'hui
alors moi quand je suis arrivé à ma
sortie d'école de commissaire à Paris en
les directeurs du quai des Orfèvres donc
des patrons du quai des Orfèvres depuis
des décennies
encourager les 3300 policiers de la
police judiciaire c'était vraiment une
machine de guerre phénoménale le 36
contre le banditisme ils encouragaient
les commissaires les inspecteurs aller
au contact du milieu pour recueillir des
renseignements voilà donc
les ressources les sources humaines
faisaient partie de l'ADN du quai des
orphels
de mon livre qui met rappelé par un
vieux voyou que je connais qui est un
ancien braqueur converti dans des
grosses escroqueries et qui me dit mais
Yves là la police judiciaire est en
train de s'écrouler complètement parce
qu'elle n'a plus d'yeux elle n'a plus
d'oreilles donc elle ne sait plus ce qui
se passe chez les voyous
et les voyous vivent actuellement une
équipe qui est bénie une époque qui est
bénie des dieux puisque en phase 2 ils
n'ont plus grand monde pour les
combattre donc la méthode à Mimile c'est
tout simplement de savoir ce qui se
passe dans le milieu de savoir qui fait
quoi qui travaille avec qui comment les
équipes de voyous sont composées qui
préparent quel coup qui a tapé le coup
c'est obtenir le meilleur de vos
informations et en échange aussi
faire quelque chose une faveur envers
ses voyous là c'est un espèce de
donnant-donnant c'est une espèce de
négociation commerciale du
gagnant-gagnant ou malgré tout les
termes de l'échange sont quand même très
déséquilibrés puisque la police doit
obtenir je dirais 90% du deal voilà
c'était en on est quand même pas très
loin d'une frontière un peu compliquée à
tenir parce que c'est pas pour ça que
plus tard c'est vous les dénoncez
d'ailleurs ces lois perdent sont venus
encadrer davantage le rôle de
l'information moi quand j'ai fait bon
la séquentiel de mon activité en
préjudiciaire au Quai des Orfèvres les
informations n'avaient pas de statut
officiel donc c'était une zone un petit
peu grise mais qui je l'ai déjà rappelé
son très utilisés dans des pays
notamment anglo-saxons ou leur
enseignement d'ailleurs porte de nom
d'incel Legends donc il y a un côté
beaucoup plus noble que dans notre pays
où quand on parle d'informateur il y a
toujours un côté un peu sulfure
sulfureux et une suspicion et les
policiers qui ont des indics parfois
sont soupçonnés par les magistrats
notamment ou par certains qui se disent
c'est curieux ces policiers ont des
résultats donc c'est qui connaissent des
voyous et s'ils connaissent des voyous
c'est que bon peut-être qu'ils ont voilà
des une proximité un petit peu anormale
et je renvoie d'ailleurs au chapitre
parce qu'on peut pas il y a tellement
anecdote votre meilleur indique c'est
Jamal ce gitan qui pouvait se faire
passer pour un membre de la famille
saoudienne la famille royale le plus
grand voleur de bijoux c'est voilà très
pidant vous racontez le braquage le coup
insensé et Place Vendôme je renvoie je
renvoie au livre pourtant c'est l'un de
vos indices que vous avez voulu protéger
en allant voir un juge et c'est là qu'on
sent qu'il y a une forme de voilà de
difficulté vis-à-vis de la magistrature
qui va vous faire plonger cette affaire
juridique et que vous allez aller en
prison enfin en détention pour le voir
et puis vous serez blanchi alors il se
trouve que ce n'est pas déjà mal pour
lequel je suis intervenu c'est puisque
Jamal faisait partie d'un clan de gitans
d'origine irakienne des bagdaddy qui
sont plusieurs centaines en Europe ils
sont implantés en France en Italie en
Espagne un peu partout
donc bien évidemment ils ont une
activité pour l'essentiel qui n'est pas
très catholique et j'étais intervenu
pour un de ces neveux
qui avait interpellé avec une faible
quantité de cannabis une trentaine de
grammes ce qui était très très peu de
choses surtout aujourd'hui quand on voit
les quantités qui circulent et cette
démarche auprès d'un juge d'instruction
de Nanterre le juge ayat principal nommé
avait été très mal perçu par ce
magistrat qui faisait partie du Syndicat
de la magistrature son épouse en était
la présidente et ce syndicat
d'administrature avait
le 36 quai des Orfèvres dans le
collimateur depuis des années parce
qu'il considérait que c'était un État
dans l'État qui avait recours aux
sources humaines aux informateurs et
donc considérer ça d'un très mauvais œil
d'ailleurs lorsque le GTR en 1988 par
les gendarmes de Versailles qui ne
connaissaient absolument rien au milieu
parisien et qui ont été chargés par le
juge Hyat d'enquêter sur mes activités
mais mes ressources et de recueillir des
témoignages
donc
ces gendarmes ce sont
procurés des témoignages de voyous que
nous avions arrêté et
vous serez voulu se venger il y a eu
une forme d'affaires dans l'affaire mais
ce qui est très intéressant de toute
façon tout ça c'est du passé vous avez
été complètement blanchi mais on
comprend aussi ce que vous disiez au
tout début sur sur les magistrats et sur
les juges peut-être une tendance à trop
de Clémence dans certaines affaires pour
les magistrats pour terminer cette
fois-ci des juges ils sont mains dans la
main avec les policiers pour dénoncer
cette réforme de la PJ en quelques mots
pourquoi il ne faut pas la faire selon
vous alors je pense que c'est une
réforme qui est très dangereuse pour la
sécurité des Français
il y a une espèce de d'unanimité contre
ce projet de réforme de la police
nationale
aussi bien les 4000 fonctionnaires de la
police judiciaire de la direction
centrale de la préjudiciaire qui sont
concernées qu'on veut faire basculer
dans des directions départementales de
préjudiciaire
ce serait ce que ceux qui ne réglera pas
les problèmes de la petite délinquance
mais ce qui fait que il ne pourront plus
traiter les grosses affaires criminelles
on va créer une usine à gaz qui ne
fonctionnera pas et la levée de bouclier
est totale sur sur le sujet quelque
chose me dit que cette réforme n'est pas
encore prête de voir le jour nous
verrons merci beaucoup merci
je bique les secrets de l'antigang flic
indique et coût tordu c'est à dire chez
plomb et vous avez travaillé avec
l'excellent frédériclin que nous
connaissons bien ici sur ce plateau sur
ce plateau je vous propose de rester
avec nous c'est l'heure d'accueillir nos
affranchis pour leur partie prix alors
ce soir le RN ou LFI qui piège qui à
l'Assemblée et bien c'est Stéphanie
Despierre qui va nous le dire dans sa
chronique pas les Bourbon Express le
parti pris de l'écho avec Fanny
guinochet Emmanuel Macron très très
mécontent du plan com autour des
coupures d'électricité et puis le regard
sur la guerre d'Isabelle Lasserre ce
soir la petite phrase de trop du
président français sur la Russie nos
affranchis les voici bonsoir mesdames
bonsoir et bienvenue sur ce plateau
Stéphanie c'est le RN qui piège la
France insoumise et qui des joues son
piège expliquez-nous je vais vous
raconter ce concours de coups tordus par
le menteur hier matin le rassemblement
national présentait ses propositions de
loi qui seront discutées dans sa niche
parlementaire du 12 janvier il y a neuf
textes et une grosse surprise Marine Le
Pen a décidé de reprendre tel quel une
proposition de loi des insoumis celle
qui réclament la réintégration des
soignants non vaccinés alors elle a déjà
été débattue dans l'hémicycle le 24
novembre lors d'une séance houleuse elle
a même failli être adoptée malgré à
l'obstruction à du camp présidentiel le
rassemblement national a donc décidé de
donner une seconde chance à ce texte
mais la surprise n'est pas du tout du
tout du goût de la gauche Caroline Fiat
la députée qui est à l'origine de cette
proposition de loi s'étrangle une mère
insoumise et en perd rassemblement
national pour une même proposition de
loi possible c'est absolument non alors
toute la journée hier elle a cherché une
parade elle a envisagé de retirer sa loi
avant de trouver une un embryon de
solution dans l'après-midi elle persuade
la commission des affaires sociales de
refuser de nommer un
venu du rassemblement national alors
vers 18h dans les couloirs de
l'Assemblée Caroline Fiat crie victoire
elle reste donc la seule et unique
rapporteur son chef de ce texte si l'on
peut dire et elle combien s'exprimer
dans l'émission le 12 janvier lors de la
journée dévolue au rassemblement
national donc hier soir ça semblait
bouclés cette affaire tout à fait sauf
que le coût du rassemblement national
sème la bazar au sein de la nupes une
partie des insoumis après réflexion et
surtout leurs alliés communistes et
socialistes flirt le piège à double
détente le piège c'est d'avoir sur un
temps de parole normalement
dévolu au rassemblement national d'avoir
une parole de gauche donc il n'est pas
question de
confondre les prises de parole notamment
dans l'hémicycle et donc il était hors
de question que nous puissions soutenir
une quelconque initiative d'une
discussion sur ce sujet dans le cadre de
la niche RN le PS et les communistes
demandaient donc le retrait du texte et
la nuit porte conseil dans ce feuilleton
manifestement et oui Myriam après une
réunion de l'état-major des députés
insoumis hier soir et encore quelques
coups de pression socialistes dans les
médias de bon matin la France insoumise
annonce en milieu de matinée que
Caroline Fiat retire sa proposition de
loi alors qu'est-ce qui a changé en
trière et aujourd'hui écoutez les
insoumis et bien ce qui a changé c'est
que en réalité en regardant bien les
textes qui sont déjà déposés par le
rassemblement national et le moment où
arrive ce texte-là dans l'hémicycle on a
compté qu'il faudrait environ 15 heures
pour pouvoir l'examiner au global et
donc les 15 heures ne permettent pas que
ce texte passe dans cette niche du
rassemblement national et puis par
ailleurs ce coût de communication du
rassemblement national il fallait quand
même y mettre un frein on peut pas
laisser le rassemblement national faire
comme si il reprenait les lois de tous
les autres groupes parlementaires c'est
un peu ce que fait le rassemblement
national ils ont pas trop bossé sur les
lois il se contente de piquer des lois
des autres pour alimenter leur niche
parlementaire
certes avec tous les amendements qui
restaient à la proposition de l'eau avec
peu de chance d'aboutir mais surtout les
insoumis et leurs alliés se sont
retrouvés en très mauvaise posture à
devoir démentir dans les médias tout
alliances avec le rassemblement national
aussitôt donc après le retrait du texte
le rassemblement national saute sur
l'occasion et dénonce une basse
reddition politique des troubles de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon c'est un petit peu
pardon comparaison n'est pas raisons
mais la maternelle voilà on est dans la
cour et les filles considèrent que on
leur a pris leur joujou si on comprend
ce qu'ils disent alors pour pas qu'on
joue avec leurs jouets bah ils font tout
pour le casser franchement c'est
pathétique c'est le degré zéro de la
politique sans dit long quand même sur
l'état d'esprit de la France insoumise
alors conclusion les insoumis ont évité
de justesse d'être associé au
rassemblement national le RN a réussi à
donner des sueurs froides à la nuit
pêche et à démontrer qu'il était ouvert
à toutes les idées enfin le camp
présidentiel s'épargne pour quelques
semaines un second débat sur la
réintégration de ces soignants non
vaccinés car il est trop tard le
rassemblement national ne peut plus
retoucher le menu de sa journée
parlementaire du 12 janvier et rajouter
une proposition 100% RN en revanche les
insoumis promettent une nouvelle loi sur
ce sujet des soignants exclus merci
beaucoup j'ai compris toutes les étapes
un frontièren même quand on est d'accord
avec lui allez comprendre Fanny vous
vouliez revenir sur les risques de
coupure d'électricité on sait que le
président n'a qu'une obsession rassuré
les Français on comprend peut-être mieux
pourquoi il a vu rouge quand on entend
ici ou là enedis par exemple propager
des scénarios de la peur et oui le
président a dit pas de panique ça va
bien se passer on est un grand pays il
fallait temporiser parce que c'était
très anxiogène la communication du
gouvernement alors certes le
gouvernement a voulu bien faire en
disant il y aura peut-être des
délaissages et justement on va se
préparer il y aura différents scénarios
vous serez prévenus tant de temps à
l'avance etc et c'est vrai que lundi
soir on a eu le porte-parole des
nudistes sur un plateau qui rajouter de
l'anxiété en disant que les personnes
qui sont à haut risque vital ne seraient
pas prioritairement protégé en cas de
coupure d'électricité alors là ça a été
effectivement l'électrochoc c'est
mauvais jeu de mots mais pour arrêter
l'aspiral d'angoisse et bien hier
Emmanuel Macron est monté au front mais
pas seulement tout le gouvernement
notamment Elisabeth borne pour essayer
de rassurer mais la graine de
l'inquiétude est quand même plantée
d'ailleurs on le voit les Français
achètent des groupes électrogènes des
ventes de bougies
montent en flèche et c'est vrai que
derrière les paroles politiques et bien
il y a quand même les experts et là
quand on les écoute on voit que la
situation n'est pas aussi simple c'est à
dire et bien s'attendre à des coupures
c'est à dire que il n'y aura peut-être
pas de coupure mais personne ne peut
dire assurément qu'il n'y en aura pas
comment ça dépendra en fait beaucoup de
la météo c'est aussi simple que ça parce
que on a très très peu de marge de
manœuvre alors quand même on nous
rassure en disant attention il y aura
pas de grandes pannes générales ça c'est
un scénario qui est complètement écarté
mais c'est vrai qu'on est dépendant
d'EDF et EDF actuellement ne va pas très
très bien c'est moins qu'on puisse dire
quasiment la moitié des réacteurs sont à
l'arrêt et c'est le problème en fait
chaque nouvelle arrêt d'un réacteur et
bien nous met en difficulté on n'a pas
de marge de sécurité juste pour vous
dire on importe actuellement de
l'électricité d'Allemagne d'électricité
produite par des charbon et on marche
sur la tête c'est pas franchement la
faute de ce gouvernement aussi c'est un
échec collectif depuis des années on n'a
pas soutenu la filière nucléaire alors
c'est vrai que quand Emmanuel Macron dit
nous sommes un grand pays le travail
d'EDF c'est de faire de l'électricité et
le travail du gouvernement c'est de
planifier bien on peut se dire que le
gouvernement les gouvernements droite et
gauche n'ont pas forcément très bien
planifiés et on pense au covid ça nous
fait penser à la petite histoire de
masse quand l'épidémie est arrivée on en
avait pas là on peut se dire que et bien
quand la bise viendra on risque de se
retrouver nous aussi un peu dépourvu on
verra ça merci beaucoup Fanny Isabelle
on termine avec vous vous voulez revenir
sur cette nouvelle petite phrase
présidentielle qui a provoqué un tollé
auprès des pays de l'espacement
d'ailleurs dans toute l'Europe et oui
Myriam il a suffi de de ces quelques
mots donner des garanties de sécurité à
la Russie prononcée le 3 décembre
dernier par Emmanuel Macron à TF1 pour
mettre le feu aux poudres alors FFS pour
for Fox sak c'est-à-dire en substance
de merde c'est ce qu'elle tweeté
l'ancien président estonien Thomas
hilves la phrase d'Emmanuel Macron
paraît en effet complètement
complètement déplacé plutôt qu'imaginer
des garanties de sécurité à donner à la
Russie qui est un pays qui est le pays
agresseur et qui détruit l'ordre
européen il aurait mieux fait quand même
de se pencher sur la manière dont on
peut aider davantage l'Ukraine alors les
pays de l'Est qui ont subi l'occupation
ou la vassilisation de la Russie et de
l'Union soviétique savent bien qu'une
paix durable à terme est absolument une
garantie de stabilité pas le moment avec
Moscou mais il considère que cette peine
ne sera pas ne pourra pas être bâti avec
Vladimir Poutine donc pour eux il est à
la fois naïf il est aussi dangereux de
discuter de la future organisation de
l'architecture de sécurité en Europe
avec un régime dont les mains sont
trempées dans le sang c'est pas la
première fois qu'il insiste
manifestement ça lui tient à cœur et
c'est pas la première fois qu'il suscite
la colère de nos alliés Emmanuel Macron
est même coutumier du fait sa dernière
injonction c'était souvenez-vous celle
il avait humilié à ne pas humilier la
Russie ça avait déjà fait absolument
scandale à la fois en Ukraine et dans
les pays de l'Est depuis le début de la
crème de la grève de la guerre pardon
depuis le 24 février Emmanuel Macron
prône un dialogue systématique avec le
président russe malgré son absence de
résultats il appelle aussi de ses vœux
ainsi c'est le feu et des négociations
c'est comme si tout en souhaitant la
victoire de l'Ukraine il s'opposait
aussi en même temps à une défaite de la
Russie alors comment vous comprenez ces
petites phrases c'est des gaffes des
erreurs politiques et bien non justement
c'est vraiment la politique russe du
président qui est en cause c'est ce en
même temps qui lui a si bien réussi
puisqu'il a réussi il a propulsé à
l'Élysée qui n'a pas du tout les mêmes
vertus en politique internationale
surtout depuis la découverte des des
atrocités à bout de chat commises par
les forces russes ces atrocités en fait
cette découverte pousse normalement les
les dirigeants à faire un choix entre
l'agresseur et l'agresser alors cette
politique elle veut aussi faire de la
France une puissance d'équilibre un pays
médiateur dans les crises mais elle a
rendu le message de la France
complètement illisible parce que la
France n'a plus les moyens de sa
politique et qualit isolée en Europe et
en plus elle s'appelait s'appuie sur
plusieurs illusions celle qui veut
croire que les rapports personnels
suffisent pour faire piller les
dictateurs et les dirigeants celles qui
prétend faire de la France un faiseur de
paix alors qu'elle est isolée en Europe
et celle qui pense que la diplomatie
peut convaincre Vladimir Poutine de
plier alors que le président russe ne
comprend que les rapports de force merci
pour ce parti pris Isabelle Lasserre
grand reporter au Figaro Fanny guidochet
l'édito écho c'est bien ça le décryptage
écho sur France Info et bien sûr
Stéphanie later à mes côtés ici même
dans cette émission merci beaucoup Yves
Jobic merci d'être venu en direct nous
parler de ses secrets de l'antigang flic
indique et coût tordu séchez plomb c'est
l'histoire d'une vie à la BRI et partout
dans les grandes instances de la police
bonne route avec ce avec ce livre très
belle soirée documentaire sur LCP avec
Jean-Pierre Grassin tout de suite
à demain